tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay
I fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
magnets
[Music]
my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything just kept
me happening
completely broke the universe
inside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
here
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara I I'm more Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]